so i'm going to introduce to you and i'm
very proud to be a friend of him i've
often said
i haven't played 10 years in the nba
this is the only doctor i know better
than dr j
this is dr waller here and uh doc has
meant so much to
not to people all over the country and
all over the world he's a former athlete
and he grew up on a farm so on a farm he
learned a lot about how you treat
farm animals he went to become a
veterinarian he also became a physician
a pathologist he studied all around the
world why animals and why humans die
he found a lot of revelations
revelations that were used in
veterinarian medicine
that he could also use on humans this is
very valuable knowledge that he gained
and he's been spreading this pledge he
was nominated for a nobel prize for
his work trace minerals so he has a
wealth of information to share with us
it's very impactful so please give your
total attention
and you're going to learn a lot to dr
joel wildick let's give him a hand
thank you
hey thank you very much appreciate all
those kind words and really appreciate
theo being here and telling his story
such a wonderful young man
kind of like my kid graduating college
i'm so proud of him and his family and
of course mike and phil we've been
working together now for 11 years
and appreciate you coming here on a
beautiful saturday morning and
we're going to share some information
with you and you've all heard of that
book purpose driven life i was fortunate
in finding out very early i think what
my purpose was for god
and my purpose i think was to spread
health information so i spent most of my
time doing that
and became very clear very quickly that
there's a lot of misinformation being
given out by the health professions
and you'll see in this presentation it
kind of guided us in the wrong
direction especially true in the black
and hispanic
communities and we came up with a
thought we called it the black
gene lies the black gene lies would be
believe it or not have you ever heard
that african-americans black people all
over the world have this terrible gene
that
makes you at a higher risk for high
blood pressure and diabetes and
cancer and other diseases well i'm here
to tell you it's a lie
okay amen it is a lie
[Applause]
and what i'm going to do in the next
hour or so is show you how it is a lie
and how we've eliminated these diseases
in animals
it's very very clear we worked with tens
of thousands of black people and
hispanics i'm from california and
i'm a minority in california there's a
65 percent of the people in california
hispanic so
i've learned to be a minority too at any
rate as
mike pointed out very nicely i think the
thing that makes my view different on
health is that
i'm a veterinarian as well as a
physician and in veterinary medicine we
don't have health insurance for animals
like we do people
and if we were to use a human health
care type of system for livestock for
instance it'd be sticker shock for you
your hamburger would cost you 275 a
pound just to pay for the health care
so we learned a long time ago in the
animal industry that we could keep the
price of animal products such as meat
and milk and
dairy and poultry and eggs down where
the average american could afford to eat
it every day
simply by eliminating health care costs
in animals now i'm going to repeat that
because it's such a profound statement
like the bible there's certain things
worth repeating right we
were able to do this by eliminating
health care costs
and it always seemed odd to me as a
veterinarian that we did that in animals
nobody was transferring that information
to people
and i spent about 20 years trying to
through the standard methods writing
scientific articles writing textbooks
lecturing to doctors and groups of size
continuing education things for them and
i was an abysmal failure i just failed
terribly
in getting medical doctors excited about
preventing curing diseases in people
with nutrition like we had done in
animals we were so successful in animals
we actually eliminated 900 different
diseases that still plague people
we did this with simple little
nutritional formulas and you've all seen
these little alfalfa pellets for mouse
pellets and rat pellets and hamster
pellets and gerbil pellets and
guinea pig pellets and rabbit pellets
and cannon dry dog and cat food
we have sheep pellets and horse pellets
and pig pellets and cat pellets and
we have dairy pellets and we have monkey
pellets and parrot pellets and chicken
pellets and trout pellets and llama
pellets
and you know you get the idea but the
reason why we put the nutrition into the
little animal pellets
is so that the animal cannot sort
through and just eat only the sunflower
seeds and the raisins every mouthful
is going to be biochemically perfect and
the purpose was to maximize production
of eggs maximize the production of meat
maximize the production of milk maximize
fertility maximize longevity eliminate
diseases because we didn't have
health insurance for these animals and
we were so effective with this little
system
that we eliminated 900 different
diseases that still plague people
well i knew this was my mission at that
point because i really understood it and
i went back to school became a physician
1978 began to use these veterinary
nutritional formulas my human patients
and i'm here to tell you that the
concept of preventing curing diseases
in people with nutritional formulas
works exactly the same
now if you were to today ask your
medical doctor or some expert
in health regardless of who they might
be college professors
or high school biology teachers doctors
nurses
they're all going to tell you that
there's no evidence to support a claim
that you can prevent and cure diseases
with
vitamins and minerals and i know you've
all heard that on tv you've heard on the
radio
you've read it that's absolutely a lie
and i'll give you some examples
raise your hand if you've ever heard of
scurvy raise your hand sure
everybody knows you can prevent cure
scurvy of the vitamin c right how about
rickets anybody here ever hear rickets
yeah you know you can prevent cure
records with vitamin d what about
anemia anybody ever hear of anemia you
don't prevent your anemia with iron and
copper and folic acid and b12 and many
other nutrients
what about goiter you know you can
prevent cure goiter with iodine and
copper and selenium
and amino acid tyrosine many other
nutrients night blindness you can
prevent and cure
with vitamin a and then there's other
ones like berry berry have never heard
of barry berry
if you talk to medical experts who say
well yeah that's only in third world
countries
people who are very poor you don't see
barry berry in america because
we're an industrialized nation and with
barry berry
you only find this in third world
countries that's not true there's an
epidemic of beriberi in america right
now and it shows up as congestive heart
failure
and the reason is americans and humans
all over the industrialized world
get their thyme or vitamin b1 from
enriched flowers
that's how most of us get vitamin b1 or
thiamine is from enriched flowers
now how many ever heard of a low
carbohydrate diet
now when you give up bread and muffins
and pastas guess what you're giving up
vitamin b1 so a lot of people who get on
these low carbohydrate diets wind up
with congestive heart failure and other
symptoms
of berry berry because they're vitamin
b1 deficient because they're not
supplementing when they get on that
low carbohydrate diet so these are sort
of things we're going to talk about
it's very exciting for me so i hope
you'll be as excited or half as excited
as i
am i'm going to start out with just a
front cover the
september 2000 issue of scientific
american almost the entire
issue was devoted to human aging and 100
year olds
and there were articles in there written
by endocrinologists
geneticists gerontologists nurses
dietitians nutritionists
and they all had their own agendas so
they had a summary at the end of this
issue telling you what you were supposed
to learn
about nutrition and longevity and
genetics and they're editorially
scratching their head because they found
out when they
kind of looked at this seriously the
people who lived to be a hundred in a
healthful way
were mean feisty rebellious patients who
did not listen to their doctors
and you all have uncles and grandparents
and parents
who are in their 80s and 90s they're
eating eggs and cooking and lard and
all this stuff and smoking the
cigarettes and not exercising they're 98
years old
and you had a cousin who went to medical
school and he was jogging and doing
everything
right and eating salads and tofu and he
died at 52.
and so the ones who did everything wrong
you salt ate red meat
ate their chicken skin use butter
instead of margarine these guys and gals
did okay and the ones who followed the
doctor's instructions didn't make it
well you don't need to do a big survey
you just have to understand that doctors
are given a lot of misinformation
now whether or not everybody in your
family died at 35 or not doesn't matter
everybody in this room has the genetic
capability lived to be
at least a hundred if you believe in the
bible which i hope you all do and i
believe you all do because you're here
this morning
in genesis it says at least 120 right
and a lot of the old testament
prophets lived to be 900 years of age so
we know we have the genetics to get
there
and the sharp version of why we all
don't live to be 100 is not because we
can't
it's because we do too much of the bad
stuff and not enough of the good stuff
that's just the way with the physical
body as well as it is with the spiritual
body right now how many who have ever
made a dish from a recipe
i don't care if it's just those
pillsbury biscuits you have to hit the
thing on the
counter you know sure we've all made
oatmeal cookies and things like that
and when you look at a cookbook or
recipe collection they always show these
beautiful pictures what your dish is
supposed to look like if you follow the
recipe
i don't know if mine ever turned out
like that but if you want to make a
fruit cake if you follow these
instructions yours is supposed to look
like that and if you want to make a pork
loin roast stuff with cranberries it's
supposed to look like that if you follow
the instructions well the same thing is
true with healthcare
we know what a 25 and a 50 and a 75 and
100 year old human looks like
because we've been using the same recipe
we've been using the same
health care systems in the
industrialized nations around the world
for at least the last
150 or 200 years 50 years ago 75 and 100
years ago they use different antibiotics
but they're still conceptually
antibiotics
25 50 75 or 100 years ago 150 years ago
we used different pain killers
but there was still painkillers
conceptually the same thing so little
has changed
if you follow the standard recipe if you
will
for the medical and health system we
have today this is what you can fully
expect to get this is what you can fully
expect to look like at age 80.
yeehaw i mean i praise god thank you sir
i'm i'm going to look like that when i'm
80.
i hope you don't okay because this is
not what we're all supposed to look like
this poor gentleman has alzheimer's
disease cataracts macular degeneration
he's had cochlear implants put in
because he was deaf no teeth because he
had periodontal disease which is
nothing more than osteoporosis of the
face and the jaw he had his thyroid
killed through radiation and then
surgery
he had angiograms angioplasties stints
put in quadruple bypass and then they
did a heart transplant has gallbladder
taken out he had a stomach stapled
bypassed and banded
he had a kidney removed he was on
dialysis uh his prostate removed
had his hips replaced his knees replaced
his shoulders replaced his feet were
amputated because he had diabetes he's
on 27 drugs for thyroid pain
lowering cholesterol and blood pressure
now if you follow the standard medical
path
this is what you're looking at everybody
gets there right
well i'm going to show you a different
recipe praise god
when i started talking to my human
patients about that they started looking
kind of worried and they said doc i
don't want to go there
i want to wind up in a nursing home and
be abused you know if i don't want to
brush my teeth in the morning i don't
want to brush my teeth in the morning i
don't want to beat me up because i don't
brush my teeth and
i don't want them sucking five thousand
dollars a month out of my assets which
should go to my kids and my grandkids
so i don't know if it's worth living to
be 100 and i thought those were
legitimate concerns
so i um began to collect birthday
announcements that people were 100 and
obituaries of people who made it to 100
just to see if it was worth going there
is it really really worth going there
and i'll show you a few of my favorites
so this fella here ralph charles from
somerset ohio is in the middle of the
state of ohio
october 1999 turned 100 and had a
beautiful birthday story about him when
he turned 100 and to me the fascinating
thing about
ralph charles was he was still piloting
commercial charter flights
at age 100 had no restrictions on his
pilot's license
or his health papers at age 100. now to
me doesn't look like what the recipe
should look like for a hundred year old
to me he looks like he's in his late 70s
early 80s and he's still animated
obviously he does his own navigation on
plane maintenance so he's
still got some stuff upstairs and so
there's hope for us all
this fella here harold stillson from
deerfield beach florida
in may of 2001 turned 101 he went out
and played golf
for his birthday and he hit his sixth
hole in one
at 101. you have to have a good enough
vision to see that stick holding up the
flag at
108 yards you have to have a good grip
on the club and you have to have good
enough eye hand coordination
to hit that little banny chicken egg
size ball into a teacup size hole 108
yards away
and you know he doesn't have alzheimer's
disease because he's animated
and he is in fact color coordinated
i thought this was a good christian
story so i'm throwing this one in
this came out just may 31st of
this year this couple celebrated their
80th year
of wedded bliss they were married 80
years he turned 105 and she turned 100
and the interviewers asked them what
they thought in his name is percy and
hers as florence aerosmith from hereford
england
they asked him what their secret was and
she said she drank a glass of red wine
every morning
and that she took a shot of whiskey
before bed
he said his success 80 year married and
being healthy for 105 years came down to
two words
and they said what are those two words
he said yes ma'am
now here's two fellas that made it
beyond a hundred this is back in march
of 1999
herbert young 112 on your left and
robert thomas on your right
103 years of age and they had won some
medals france's legion of honor which is
kind of like their
medal of honor like we have here in the
first world war and they're invited to
go to france and pick up medals and
things and
drink a little bit of french wine and it
looks like they're having a good time
they're from new york city it doesn't
seem to matter what you eat
if you do two things to live to be
beyond a hundred
there's a common thread and i'm going to
give you the sharp version now in the
long version in a minute
the short version is you have to keep
the amount of carbohydrates in your life
down and i'll show that to you in a
second
and you need to keep the mineral levels
in your life up now one of the blessings
i've had in my life i've spent two years
out in the bush in south africa working
on big
conservation projects and i lived in the
bush for that whole two years with the
exception of three days in the city the
rest of the time i lived out in the bush
and so i know how primitive villages
exist and live
this gal here dorama phoebe from south
africa was born in june of 1881
in 1995 she turned 114 and this was a
birthday announcement this isn't an
obituary this is a birthday announcement
and she was asked what did she attribute
her long and healthy life to and she
said
she observed the biblical tenet of honor
thy father and thy mother and i thought
that was really
really quite good i really appreciated
that of course when i grew up
my first chores we grew up in a little
bee farm and i was so excited when i
first started working with the animals
and
i'd do it my dad told me and i come up
to my desk hey what's my reward i did
exactly as you told me
he says son i'll let you live another
day
and so i knew it was important
what does it honor their mother and
their father i thought that was good
okay and then she said she
ate locust has grasshoppers not the
trees she ate grasshoppers pumpkin seeds
tortoise meat wild herbs dried fruit and
a cup of coffee that was her diet
and you notice there's no bread no rice
no potatoes no corn
no hush puppies she got her protein from
the grasshoppers and the tortoise meat
she got her essential fatty acids from
the pumpkin seeds she got her folic acid
beta-carotene which is kind of a
pre-vitamin a
and vitamin c from the wild herbs that
she ate green before they dried
and then a little bit of phytonutrients
and antioxidants from the dried fruit
so she had a low carbohydrate diet that
was rich in phytonutrients
but where did she get her minerals how
did she get those minerals up did she
supplement the answers yes
i'll tell you more about that in a
minute but in her case out in the bush
in south africa
just when i grew up my first first first
chore when i was four years old before
they let me work with the livestock
i had to do something every day how many
of you grew up in a rural situation
where you had wood as a fuel for heating
or cooking anybody yet here
okay good what did you do with the wood
ashes every morning came out of the
stove
we were in the garden didn't they when
the garden well wood ashes aren't just
ashes
wood ashes are plant minerals wood ashes
or plant minerals are left when you burn
away the carbon in the wood
as we put those plant minerals in the
garden the
onions and radishes and peas and beans
and tomatoes and squash and okra
all took those plant minerals up we ate
the vegetables
and we got our minerals indirectly that
way they would also mix the plant
ashes the plant minerals in with their
food because they didn't have baking
powder
and they lived inland and salt was a
very expensive thing so
instead of using salt they would mix the
plant ashes into their food
they had two ways that they actually
took in minerals
i thought that was very exciting to see
them do exactly what i had done as a kid
now this is from the herald sun which is
the sydney australian newspaper back in
march of 2003 in sydney australia and
australia is located kind of like where
atlanta is in the united states
in that southeastern quadrant it says
here a brazilian believed to be the
world's oldest woman who's died at the
age of 124
maria etalovina dos santos died of a
stroke in salvador and her
birth certificate says she was a
descendant of african slaves and she was
born july 15 1878
so you know you have the genetics to
live well beyond a hundred because the
bible tells you so and people
every once while do it right and so we
need to know what it is they're doing
i thought this was kind of important she
enjoyed a long healthy life and i
guarantee you
if she was born of african slaves that
she was born in a little straw hut
caulked with cow manure
and mud and her mama had to pee in the
dust to make mud to smear all over that
child
to keep the fleas and the mosquitoes and
the flies from eating her because they
didn't have screen windows they didn't
have hospitals in clinics
and they didn't have doctors as we know
them today they didn't have
social security they didn't have
medicare and medicaid
and yet she did pretty good set a record
124 with all those things that
are missing that we think are important
here's another gal
with an african heritage this lady here
elizabeth israel from the little
caribbean island of dominica
was born january 27 1875 and in january
2001 turned 126
and when she was asked what does she
attribute her healthy long life to she
says i grew up eating food grown without
chemical fertilizer
what did her parents use as fertilizer
wood ashes which are the plant minerals
that are left when you burn
away the carbon in the wood i'm going to
show you one more and then i'll kind of
tell you what i think you should learn
from these and we'll get into the meat
of this
presentation this next obituary is not
the oldest one that i have
this is kind of middle-aged compared to
some of the obituaries i had which were
up in the 200s
but this gal here an iranian woman died
in january of 1995 this is written up in
the rocky mountain news
out of denver colorado and she's an
iranian woman by the name of mizumi
dusty
and said that she died at age 161
it was printed in the denver newspaper
rocky mountain news
and you have to give a lot of
credibility to this obituary because she
was survived
by six living children ranging in age
from 120 to 128.
they hadn't even left home to go to
college yet
and her oldest son said his mother had
never visited a doctor
taken any chemical medications only she
uses herbs in her life
what you're going to find fellas is that
the people who live the longest
are the ones who are furthest from what
we consider to be necessary
and good medical care the people who
live the longest are the ones who are
furthest from
what we think of as necessary and good
medical care and you'll see why in just
a second
the first statistic we have to look at
is the united states
we in america spend more than half the
entire world's annual expenditure for
health care
the entire world right now is spending
2.7 trillion with a t
dollars every year for health care and
out of that 2.7 trillion dollars
america alone spends 1.8 trillion we
spend five times as much for our
healthcare as we do for our defense
1.8 trillion dollars for health care now
if we were number one
you have to say well that's expensive
but go for it because
it's worth it we're number one right
let's have a look in april of 1990 the
world health organization
and the center for disease control right
out of atlanta here did a study on the
top 32 industrialized nations
and they were shocked to find out when
it came to life expectancy or longevity
and health
the united states ranked 17th there were
16 other countries in april of 1990
whose people were healthier and live
longer than us
the japanese came in number one at 79.1
we came at 17th at 75
and the japanese according to western
doctors do everything wrong
they're heavy smokers they and i don't
smoke and i'm not promoting smoke i'm
just giving the statistics
they're heavy smokers 68 of the japanese
smoke three to five packs of cigarettes
a day
yet they have 85 percent less cancer
than we do and they have 85 percent less
cardiovascular disease than we do the
japanese are heavy salt users they
consume
12 to 15 grams of salt today which is
two heaping tablespoons of salt
we're supposed to consume less than one
gram of salt a day yet they have 85
percent less
cardiovascular season we do and they do
not have a spoken word for hypertension
because they rarely get it unless they
come to united states and eat like us
i'm going to throw in one more little
variant here the french came in 11th at
75.9
and you can say well that was a bad
study let's redo it they did 10 years
later
june 2000 they came out with another
study again it was the world health
organization
and the center for disease control of
atlanta georgia they did a good job and
of course the interesting thing was
japan remained number one
but they dropped from 79.1 down to 74.5
huge drop and yet they remain number one
but this is our chance to catch up with
them and surpass them remember
we're spending 1.8 trillion dollars a
year for healthcare we're spending
about 63 percent of the world's annual
expenditure for healthcare
and the french moved up from 11th to 3rd
they went from 75.9 down to 73.1 but
they moved up in ranking
and this is called the french paradox
because the french consume more fat than
any other culture on earth
can you imagine a french chef cooking in
canola oil and margarine
they cook everything in butter and lard
and chicken fat and cream
right and yet they moved up in ranking
they dropped in actual numbers but they
did move up in ranking so this is called
the french paradox
you will not find the united states in
the top 20 because june of 2000 we had
dropped to 24th
because we went from 75 average lifespan
to 70. now
in june of 2000 the actual was that
there were 23 other countries whose
peoples live longer than us
the newest update and this is from the
special health issue of newsweek
it's a special edition the future of
medicine they're talking about genetics
and the usual stuff that medicine talks
about new drugs new procedures
and in the very first article in this
newsweek magazine the very first article
it said america has built the world's
highest tech medical system i don't
think anybody could argue with that
because every country sends their
brightest young medical students the
united states for the residencies and
internships and so forth
yet the nation now ranks 46th in life
expectancy now there's 45 other
countries whose peoples live longer than
us
do you feel that we're getting the bang
for the buck when it comes for health
care
no no we would not tolerate this in any
other industry
and nobody knows more than the black
community how to change an industry
if you have a failed and corrupt system
you don't use it
you have a failed and corrupt system you
don't use it you don't ask for more
money to fix it
this is a very interesting statistic
phil oliver got this for me
this is per hundred thousand white
people and per hundred thousand black
people
per hundred thousand each year in
america one thousand thirty seven and
eight
die per hundred thousand black males 593
black females
by contrast about two-thirds of that
number
only two-thirds of white males will die
664 compared to 1037
and when females white females only 384
die compared to 593 that's per 100 000
population
okay so we have a lot of work to go here
and then you look at the mortality for
kids
neonatal that means newborns 12 per 100
000 of male
blacks 10 per hundred thousand of female
blacks newborn babies
half for the white male and female so we
have a lot of work to do
but it's doable because it's not genetic
now some of the things we need to change
are fun
and you will do it you will start today
when i show it to you because it's easy
it's fun and it'll make you live longer
the first one i want to share with you
is this one it says frequent sex
helps you live longer yes
god god gave the equipment to use right
praise god okay now this was
give me an order
was published in the british medical
journal back in december of 1997
and basically to make a sharp version of
it they said men who had sex twice a
week
actually live 50 longer than men who
only have sex once a month
now what if you have sex three times a
week you know
and so you need to um make some kind of
contract with your wives
wives wife wife
wife wife okay i'm in the right group
here
now you got to watch it because once
they know this if they want to get rid
of you you know they know how to do it
also the same year december 1997 this is
a wonderful study
it was done by harvard medical school
the department of public health and what
they did was look at the longevity of
both men and women
and the reason why it's all these funny
little boxes and different shaped boxes
they went county by
county now this is one of the more
difficult things you're going to have to
do to live to be a 100 and healthful way
this is called the heart attack and
stroke belt of america both
for men and women the people who live
the longest in america
you'll see them in blue purple and dark
purple
as the upper midwest here you're looking
at wisconsin minnesota north and south
dakota eastern montana
northern iowa eastern nebraska and
kansas
these are the longest-lived people in
america the shortest lived people in
america live here
guess where atlanta is
in fact the lifespan here in atlanta is
20 years shorter than the people who
live in the upper midwest
your average lifespan here is 20 years
shorter
okay than it is in the upper midwest
it's not genetic but it is cultural
the reason why this is the heart attack
and stroke belt and
cancer belt of america is not because of
genetics
is because of the way people eat the
difference is people in the upper
midwest come from scandinavian
and german backgrounds and they stew and
roast and boil everything
how do people eat here fry
fried chicken and i
talked briefly with pastor dollar and he
says how are you going to get a black
man to give up fried chicken
so this is going to be a tough one but
if you do this one thing today you will
add 20 to 50 healthy years to your life
if you take this home and do nothing
else but this
you got to give up fried fish and fried
chicken you got to give up fried hush
puppies you got to give up fried
potatoes
you got to give up fried okra you got to
give up fried chitlins
everything fried you got to give up
fried stuff and if you do that that
alone will add 20 to 50 healthful years
to your life
and the reason is fried foods contain
free radicals trans fatty acids that
increase your risk of cancer heart
disease and alzheimer's disease
a thousand percent whereas if you boil
and stew and roast your food
you don't get those free radicals and so
this is a suicide area
if you keep eating fried foods that just
comes down to the the bottom line
if we can get our community in the
southeastern part of the united states
and if we do that and we kind of spread
that amongst our loved ones
we're going to add long healthful years
to their life now how many of you
remember a guy the name of art link
letter anybody remember art link letter
okay good some of us old enough remember
him
he's 92 years old now and still alive he
aspired to want to live to be 100 and he
was willing to be proactive and
do it he was inspired to want to live to
be 200 by a group of people called the
hunzas
who live in what is today known as
eastern pakistan all this war is going
on there now
but back in the 1920s 1930s they were
the longest lived and healthiest people
on earth
a novel was written about them it was a
pulitzer prize-winning novel called lost
horizon written by james hilton
art link letter read this novel and he
was excited about because
essentially what the book said was there
was this place in this very hostile
mountain
where it was kind of like a branch
office of the garden of eden everything
was perfect and if you lived in that
place and ate
their food and did what they do and so
forth you could live to be two three
hundred years of age
well there is a place called hunsa an
art link letter hired an eye doctor by
the name of alan banik to go there and
find out what their secret was to make
the long story short
they farmed at 19 500 feet elevation
which is like three times timberline
they could not grow potatoes they could
not grow corn they could not grow rice
because of the elevation
very short growing season only 45 days
so they didn't have the traditional
carbohydrate sources that most everybody
else has
and without even thinking about it
because where they live they had a very
low carbohydrate diet they lived on
mutton
which is adult sheep and they had lamb
and goat meat and they had chicken
and eggs and butter and yogurt and they
cooked in butter and water that's all
they had
they're very poor they couldn't trade
even for oils and things so they only
use butter and water to cook with
they had a very low carbohydrate high
animal protein diet
now the other thing they did that he
noted in this book is very clearly
stated in his book that he observed that
they took the wood ashes the plant
minerals are left when you burn away the
carbon in the wood and put them in their
garden
and mix it in their food so they had the
high mineral intake
and they had the low carbohydrate intake
and that apparently was their secret
this is a beautiful story here i picked
up in houston texas about a year ago
it was a story about a primitive guy by
the name of bruno opaza one of bolivia's
indigenous amira indians he's holding a
little bucket of llama
or dried llama manure which he's feeding
his kitchen fire with you notice
that's a little one foot by two foot
cast iron stove and the interesting
thing about the amyra indians
is that they live around a lake called
lake titicaca and he's from bolivia and
there's people from peru and people from
chile that
live right around lake titicaca and all
those people that live around lake
titicaca are very primitive
like bruno paza no indoor plumbing no
electricity they have no hostels no
clinics no medicaid no medicare
they have no pharmacies no
pharmaceuticals
nothing that we think of as being
absolutely essential and yet they have
100 year old per 500 people we have 300
year olds
for 10 000 they have 10 times as many
hundred year olds as we have
they have 10 times as many hundred year
olds as we have
they have nothing except raw materials
they're putting those raw materials in
their food every day
those plant minerals in their food every
day we need raw materials
and people ask me well what did people
do in the old days did jesus supplement
with minerals the answer was yes
in our book we call hell's kitchen we
have a cd you'll go along with it hell's
kitchen
this cd hell's kitchen the book hell's
kitchen talks about
how long ago the people used wood ashes
or plant minerals in their food and
their gardens
and it goes back before written history
we know this from the anthropological
and the archaeological records that
people before written history would do
this
even moses i'm sure he did not take the
wood ashes out into the garden because
he was raised as a prince of egypt right
but i'm sure they had their slaves do
that
and then there was jesus he was raised
as a little jewish boy so i guarantee
you
that he took the wood ashes outside like
all the other little jewish boys did and
put them in the garden
and this remained the same from before
written history until
monday september 4th 3 o'clock in the
afternoon 1882. i'll repeat that date
very important
we know the exact instant monday
september 4th 3 o'clock in the afternoon
when this man changed everything anybody
know who he is
as thomas edison and at that moment at
three o'clock in the afternoon monday
september 4th
1882 his chief electrical technician a
guy by the name of jonathan leaves
in new york city on pearl street
overlooking the construction of the
brooklyn bridge gives you a little time
sense
turned on the switch for the first
commercial electric generating plant
by 1909 there was at least a half a
dozen patented
electrical kitchen appliances including
toasters and skillets and waffle irons
and blenders and irons and things like
that
and by 1950 wood as a fuel had been
completely replaced
with natural gas propane electricity
liquid paraffin kerosene heating oils
how many wood ashes are left over when
you use those fuel so give you a hint
it's a numeral that looks like this and
begins with a zero zero
okay and so nobody sat down there were
no senate investigation what's going to
be the impact on our health
when we stopped using wood as a fuel
nobody asked that question they were
just glad to get rid of that chore
they sold all these other stoves and
appliances by saying you didn't have to
wake up
two hours early to build the fire and
get the fire right for bacon biscuits
for breakfast
so most of the diseases we're going to
talk about fall into mineral deficiency
diseases
as a result of that one invention
electricity
and we're not going to be able to talk
our wives into going back to wood stoves
they'll chase out of the house of the
broom right but
we do have to make up the difference we
have to consciously supplement otherwise
we're going to break down
we need 90 essential nutrients they're
called essential nutrients gentlemen
because we cannot manufacture we must
consume them every day either as
food or supplements number two if
they're missing frame length of time
days weeks months or years
you get some horrible collection of
degenerative diseases many of which are
disabling many of which are life
threatening we need 60 minerals every
day not once a year but every
day we need 16 vitamins every day 12
essential amino acids every day
three essential fatty acids every day
and fortunately for us fortunately for
us
our food plants our grains vegetables
fruits and nuts can take carbon dioxide
out of the air
use the sun's energy in a process known
as photosynthesis to manufacture long
carbon chains
and the plant will take these carbon
chains and configure them into starch
which is potatoes and grains it'll
configure them into sugar which is fruit
and sugar cane vitamins amino acids and
fatty acids
and it is possible it is possible with
the grace of god
and a lot of effort on our part to get
all the vitamins amino acids and fatty
acids we need by eating right and
selecting the right food and preparing
it right and storing it right
but most people don't take the three
hours a day that that would
require everybody runs and buys a box of
this throws it in the stove cooks it and
eats it and
we're all eating out of boxes and things
and even if we're eating fresh foods is
very difficult as you'll see in a minute
to get everything we need
now the problem is plants can in fact
make vitamins amino acids fatty acids
but plants cannot manufacture minerals
you notice that two-thirds of the
essential nutrients are minerals
we need 60 minerals to be happy a plant
only needs nine
i have a degree in agriculture so i'm
going to assure you that plants only
need nine to be fertile and happy and
do their thing but if a farmer were to
put in nine minerals
in every crop it cost you thirty five
dollars a year for
your corn and so he's not gonna do it he
couldn't sell any
and so they learned 150 years ago that
they could put in three elements into
the soil npk
nitrogen phosphorus potassium a very
cheap very simple fertilizer
you see this these three letter
designations on garden fertilizers and
lawn fertilizers npk
and different configurations depending
on the plant it will give them the
maximum yields in terms of tons and
bushels or acres so that's what they use
npk
that's why they use these little alfalfa
pellets with all the vitamins and
minerals in it to give their animals
because they know the farmers know and
the veterinarians know
that you can't get everything you need
from your food even in the same field on
the farmers property
even in the same field the farmer's
property you cannot get everything you
need because row number one might have
16 minerals in it
row number five might have zero row
number ten might have three row number
fifteen might have six
row number twenty might have zero and so
it's to throw the dice when you wake up
in the morning
and you eat some whole grain pancakes or
11 grain bread made into toast
or you have your whole grain cereals
it's to throw the dice and which row in
the field that that grain grew in
and are you going to bet your life every
morning when you wake up i mean would
you play the game that if you threw dice
and you got a seven in any combination
uh two and a five four and three one on
the six
any combination you get a seven you'd
get to live another day
but if you got any other number you
would die and i got your clothes and
your shoes in your car and everything
how many would voluntarily play that
game nobody you'd have to be insane to
play that game
well if you're not supplementing every
morning to guarantee those 60 minerals
16 vitamins 12 essential amino acids and
three essential fatty acids
that's the game you're playing that
exactly is the game you're playing
this is kind of a soft business magazine
i'm sure many of you have seen it u.s
news world report
this is the january february issue of
2005 says a special health issue who
needs doctors
your future physician might not be an md
and you may be better off
they're talking about nurse
practitioners they're talking about
chiropractors naturopathic doctors
traditional
chinese medical doctors herbalist
acupuncturists and so forth
and just a few things you've got to
watch on doctors or human beings
and they fail like most human beings or
groups of human beings
doctors say they'd lie to get insurance
to pay this is a big study it was
published by the
generally american medical association
back in 1999. study finds doctors skip
key steps to treatments
doctors fail to take about half to
recommend the steps for treating high
blood pressure diabetes two diseases are
very important
in the black community i'll give you a
couple more statistics here and then
we'll get into some specific diseases
but i think these are very very useful
and i'll tell you how to solve these
problems
this came out november 1996 this was a
study by harvard medical school in the
department of public health
examining a casualty account now those
are military terms casualty count
they don't use casualty count in the
hospital look that up in the dictionary
that's military terms were killed and
wounded right casualties
the annual toll on medical harm that's
each year in hospitals alone in america
1.3 million physical injuries
by doctors negligence 180 000 deaths
each year in hospitals
three years later this came out this is
november 1999.
medical mistakes are the eighth top
killer americans behind cardiovascular
disease
cancer diabetes alzheimer's disease
gastrointestinal problems liver problems
kidney problems and doctors now you got
to give them credit they did improve
by december 2002 they went from the
eighth
leading cause of death in america to the
number three leading cause of death in
america because they moved up to killing
250 000 americans each year in hospitals
this was published in the journal
american medical association the study
was done by johns hopkins school of
public health
department of medical school right out
of atlanta georgia
seven and a half years ago two million
americans are infected each year in
hospitals alone as a result of medical
negligence two million
and despite intravenous antibiotics
around the clock nursing care 90 000 and
this year is 103 000 died
out of these 2 million year after year
after year one more statistic and then
i'll tell you what i think we should do
about it
every day in america there's 40 drug
errors in each hospital in america it
turns out to be 2.2 million drug errors
a year
2.2 million drug areas of which 140 000
die now if you've been good with math
you've been keeping track of these
numbers
that turns out to be 5.8 million
casualties a year killed
injured and infected in the hospitals in
america each year 5.8 million casualties
a hospital is not a safe place
i don't know how else to say it you
should not aspire to take a day off
so you can go to the hospital i'm going
to take a sick day and i'll just run to
the hospital you know
you want to be careful there fellas
that's a very dangerous place
how do we solve this problem more money
well we're already spending more money
than all the other nations in the world
put together we rank now 46th
in longevity and health no so it's not
more money
more technology we already have 250 000
drugs with the exception of antibiotics
which do kill bacterial infections
strep throat and gangrene and things
like that with the exception of these
antibiotics which is about 500 in the
pdr you take them out
that leaves 249 500 drugs left in the
pdr that a doctor has available to
treat diseases there's not a single one
of those designed to cure anything
they're all designed to make you feel
good
but they're not designed there's not a
single other drug other than antibiotics
designed to cure anything
if doctors were to cure all the diseases
which they could in a couple of days
they'd be out of work and so how do we
solve the problem we have to do things
ourselves
how many of you have ever put in fuel in
a car or truck anybody ever put fuel in
a car truck
good how many ever changed the tire in a
car truck excellent
how many of you have ever washed a car
or truck huh yeah
okay how many people vacuumed the inside
of a car truck have you ever added oil
to a car
truck okay good how many have you ever
kind of
done that little touch-up you know when
you scratch your car those little
touch-up paint things sure
have you ever heard of autozone pet boys
napa auto parts shooks checkers
i mean everybody knows where their local
store is right you go down there and you
get spark plugs you gap those things you
do all that stuff yourself
get the right paint color and the mats
for the floor and so on
and other more complicated parts for the
car and stereos and all that kind of
thing
we do this because of a variety of
reasons number one people got tired of
being ripped off by the dealerships you
going to get your oil changed for eight
bucks you come out with a 300
bill and leaks all over your driveway
because they didn't tighten those bolts
right
and so you can save all that labor cost
and do it yourself for 12 bucks
it's at 80 or 300 bucks right and so
people began to do these things
themselves same thing is true
with home depot lowe's menards how many
heard of them yeah we all live in those
places because we learned we can get
materials and parts and tools cheaper
and if you don't know how to put
shingles on a roof they'll give you a
free class they'll even put those
bundles of shingles on your roof
are you at no extra cost if you buy the
nails and the shingles from them
how come we don't do that for health
care well it's complicated you need to
go to school for 14 years you need to
know how to read latin
that's not true
that's absolutely not true doctors other
than a lot of fancy furniture they have
less than 100 bucks worth of stuff in
their examining room
they got a blood pressure cuff a
stethoscope they got a thermometer
they've got a little aaa battery pen
light to look in your eyes and down your
throat with and you snatch it out of
their pocket look at it says fires or
pharmaceuticals they didn't pay for that
it was given to him by a drug dealer
so you can get all those things from the
pharmacy without a prescription and
you'll notice that it costs you about 65
bucks for all that stuff totaled
together
and if you don't know how to use them
there's a little insert in the box they
come in
written in the fifth grade reading level
in eight different languages including
spanish
you can do this it's very simple to do
that you should learn how to take your
own blood pressure you should learn how
to
check your own temperature and all that
kind of stuff grandma used to do that
but you kind of feel how you're under
the doctor now
we need to do more of that stuff
ourselves with the exception radiology
with the exception of things like
cat scans and mris and x-rays and
ultrasounds
you can get any test from the pharmacy
without a prescription that a doctor
would send you to a hospital for
i know it shocks most people for about a
buck 50 a test strip they come 10 in a
bottle it's 15
a bottle you get these test strips you
just pee on and you can tell if you have
sugar in your urine
you can tell if you have blood in your
urine if you have protein in your urine
if you have infection
in your kidneys or your bladder for a
buck fifty it saves you eighteen dollars
and fifty cents on the co-payment
plus it saves you the gas money the
parking and getting all dressed up and
your extra shaving lotion all that kind
of stuff
it saves all that stuff so you save
about 40 bucks by doing that yourself
you also get a test strip to find out
what your blood sugar is you're
empowered to test your own blood sugar
when you have diabetes
you can test what your blood cholesterol
is yourself you get what's called an
occult blood test it's
blood in your bowel movement you can't
see with the naked eye but this is an
early warning signal colon cancer
maybe ulcerative colitis gastric ulcers
blood sucking parasites all those kind
of things
for a couple of bucks two three dollars
you can get those test strips
and you can do that yourself you don't
have to go in once a year to get a three
foot galvanized pipe put up your rump
for them to look in there right
you don't have to do that you can do
that little test yourself for three
bucks in the privacy of your home a
little brown bag nobody needs to know
you're doing it
and then there's all these tests to see
if women are premenopausal
postmenopausal menopausal there's tests
to see if they're pregnant seven dollars
and 95 cents
test in any drug store why they have to
go in two visits and all these tests and
physical exams for 500 bucks by an ob
gyn to find out if they're pregnant you
can do it in your your own home in 30
seconds for 7.95
what about dental work i love this one
usually when you're filling is going to
fall out or your crown is going to come
off
it's right in the middle of the day on
christmas or easter or thanksgiving
right
and our new year something like that and
so you call the dentist it's thirteen
hundred bucks for a temporary then two
weeks later you gotta go back and get
the permanent one
put in for another thirteen hundred
bucks you can go to a
pharmacy or even a grocery store where
they sell dental floss
and right next to the dental floss is a
little bubble wrap package of a
temporary filling it costs you five
bucks
has all the instructions all the little
tools and disinfectants and things you
need to put them in
and they will last 10 years now even if
it only falls out every 10 years you can
afford that right
keep doing it yourself do you need
stitches every time you cut yourself and
the answer is no
it's not shooting blood all over the
place if you can take a towel or
washcloth and you can stop it bleeding
just a little kind of a half a pound of
pressure
you can wash that thing out with a
disinfectant and put some colloidal
silver in there
antibacterial soap you can use steri
strips and butterfly bandages
you're going to save hours and hours and
hours sitting in the emergency room you
know being abused and emerging from
people coughing all over you and
all that kind of stuff and so the more
this kind of thing we do ourself and
avoid
a failed and corrupt system when you can
guess what price is going to come down
that's called the free market system
because they want to attract you back in
how many of you are buying your own home
how many are buying your own home great
great asset one of the best things you
can do is somehow get to buy your own
home
and here's why most people when they buy
health insurance for a family of five
it costs you 300 500 800 a month
depending on
if anybody's been sick in the family
let's just say for round figures 500
a month for health insurance 50
deductible 100
deductible if you get a 2 000
line of credit or a 5 000 line of credit
on your home stick that certificate in
your lock box and don't buy
a snowmobile with it don't do anything
with it just put it in there there's no
interest
on it you'll have it as long as you own
your house don't have to make payments
when you do make payments it's stuck
back in the mortgage so that you're
going to take 30 years to pay that 5 000
bucks off right
so you're looking at 20 bucks a month
very very low then you go to your health
insurance guy and you say i want
a 5 000 deductible health insurance
policy you know how much your monthly
premium is going to be
your monthly premium is going to be 100
bucks
at 5 000 deductible you can use that
extra 4 500
every month for your family instead of
being insurance poor how many of you
heard the term insurance poor
okay it was worth your coming here today
if you're buying your own home to get
those
get those lines of credit get your
insurance premiums down so you can
invest in your family
instead of the insurance company anybody
know who this fella is
einstein well he died at age 76 of
something a turkey wouldn't even die
from even though he won the nobel prize
in physics in 1921
he died of a ruptured aortic aneurysm
which is caused by copper deficiency and
one of the
early signs of a copper deficiency is
white hair
another early sign of copper deficiency
is a breakdown the elastic fibers of
your body you see all these wrinkles in
the skin he's got the elastic fibers and
the skin broken down
you can get spider veins varicose veins
hemorrhoids hemorrhoids are nothing more
than varicose veins in the wrong place
i practiced for 12 years in portland
oregon i can always tell when a new
patient had hemorrhoids because they
would always whisper
i don't know what the connection is but
they would always whisper when they come
in
they say things like doc wallet you know
my my hemorrhoids are acting up
i need you to look at them and i said
well i'll take your word for it ralph
once you've seen one hemorrhoid you've
seen them all you know
you got to break down the elastic fibers
in your arteries get a balloon or a
bubble in the weakest area called an
aneurysm if you have a small one
rupturing your brain
you get a bleeding type of stroke if you
have a larger one rupture in your brain
you die suddenly if you have a
small one rupture in your eye you get a
detached retina and they have this
wonderful technology now where they can
take lasers without even opening up your
eye they can
spot weld that retina back down and
repair your vision i mean that is a
miracle surgery right
but does it solve the systemic copper
deficiency
no unless the doctor urges you to get on
some
nutrients a program that has copper in
it guess what
you're still going to die of ruptured
aneurysm two years later because you
didn't heed that warning
you didn't heed that warning again these
books back there have all these warnings
there's over 500 early warning signals
of these diseases
that plague us as human beings and once
you know what they are you can adjust
your diet you can add a supplement the
early warning signals go away you're
going to add 20 years of your life
it is that simple if you can make
oatmeal cookies from a recipe you can do
it
now as mike said i didn't always have
this tummy i was an athlete i was a
captain of the wrestling team in high
school in college university of missouri
only weighed 127 pounds and only had
three grams of fat on me at that time
but i read a story that said exercise
kills there's never been a professional
athlete ever lived be a hundred
now i found out that's not true anymore
there was a baseball player that lived
behind
he lived be like a hundred years one day
boom he fell over dead
but there's never been a football player
there's never been a basketball player
there's never been a hockey player
there's never been a runner
there's never been a swimmer who's lived
to be a hundred
and the reason is exercise without
supplementation is suicide
when you're sweating from exercise or
physical labor you're not just sweating
out water
you're sweating out of soup that
contains all your essential nutrients
if you're just drinking soft drinks in
water or worse yet
gatorade you're not going to do very
well and i'll show why in a second
the guy who invented the power bars
brian maxwell 51
a multi-multi-millionaire at age 51 of a
heart attack
won 14 marathons in the world games in
olympics
very well known long distance runner
died of a heart attack
beautiful young girl ronelda pierce 19
years old
the pride of florida state university
girls basketball 19 years old
she was going to be the wnba's new
superstar she's going to be the michael
jordan
of basketball for women and she died at
age 19 of a ruptured aneurysm a copper
deficiency
there's never been a nobel prize winner
lived to be a hundred there's never been
a professional athlete except a baseball
player
lived to be a hundred reggie lewis
captain of the
boston celtics had a heart attack a
cardiomyopathy heart attack a selenium
deficiency at age 27
well the dream team of cardiology was
trying to figure out what to do with him
to get him back on the floor could they
do a heart transplant and still play
basketball
he died of a second cardiomyopathy heart
attack because nobody gave him 10 cents
worth of selenium
but justice has a way of coming around
god is very good about that
in his own way in his own time a year
and a half later the chief
the captain of the dream team of
cardiology one dr w thomas had died of
the same thing at age 48.
now if he is my cardiologist he died of
a heart attack at age 48. would you keep
doing
would you keep doing what he was telling
you to do now if he said salt was no
good man i'd take the
top over there
if he says that exercise is good for i
just lay there man
i wouldn't even blink nothing even
looking
this young fella here corey stringer
from the minnesota vikings he was a
great
offensive lineman a tackle and he died
at age 27
of heat stroke here's a multi-million
dollar athlete dying of a heat stroke
ignorant people who can't even read
living out in the deserts of africa they
never die of heat stroke
it's 120 degrees out there he has all
these team doctors and all the trainers
and he dies of a heat stroke the reason
is when he collapsed
i'm sure his internal temperature is 105
106 or more
they called the ambulance 10 minutes
later they come rolling up and then they
put him in there they wheel him to the
hospital and he was dead by the time he
got there
well what they should have done was
taken the garden hose that they're
filling that gatorade bucket with
and wash that guy down take his clothes
off give him an animal with that cold
water get his core temperature down
and he'd lived he would have lived if as
soon as he collapsed
if they would have put that cold water
all over him and given him a cold water
enema right there
he'd lived but everybody's so dependent
on those doctors
that they don't even do the simplest of
things to save their buddies
and that's where we have to change that
amen
okay amen i like that kid
this gal here an olympic legend will
rudolph triple gold medalist died of
brain cancer at age 54
as caused by a deficiency of a trace
mineral
if you just supplement with that trace
meal the odds of you getting a brain
cancer is almost zero
but if you're sweating and you're just
drinking pop of some kind or another
or water how much of that you're going
to get zero okay you all recognize this
fella
walter payton died at age 45 waiting for
a liver transplant
they had just given him some selenium
he'd still be alive today
but he's waiting for that liver
transplant that's right he died of a
selenium deficiency a certain type of
liver cirrhosis
is caused by a selenium deficiency do
football players sweat
is there any selenium and gatorade no
i want to talk about high blood pressure
how many ever heard that black people
get high blood pressure
that's right and we know it's a black
gene because doctors tell us so right
the stealth killer america's high blood
pressure crisis is spinning out of
control
now dogs and cats and parakeets and
horses and cows and pigs and every
animal you can think of get high blood
pressure
they can get it they don't get it
because in those little pellets we give
them we put the minerals in there so
they don't get high blood pressure
because we don't have insurance
to pay for calcium channel blockers and
beta blockers
whether you believe it or not how many
have you ever heard that salt has
something directly or indirectly do with
hybrid pressure
yeah if you don't raise your hand you're
a sleeper already because i know you
heard that
what's the first thing a good farmer
puts out for his livestock salt block
salt block salt lick
there's nobody out in the pasture
telling that cow she's limited to one
lick a day is there
i refuse to believe my human patients
are dumber than a cow
a little more than eight years ago this
came out as present at the annual
meeting american heart association in
portland oregon
doctors lack proof that too much salt is
unhelpful after years of telling healthy
people that too much salt isn't good for
them
researchers still don't have solid
evidence to back up that claim
same study just a little more detail the
study found that people who limited
their salt intake to a thousand
milligrams or one gram a day which is
what doctors want you to do
had six times more heart attacks had 600
more heart attacks and those who defy
their doctors and ain't double that
amount
remember september 2000 scientific
american the people who defied their
doctors and did their own thing live
longer than the ones who did what the
doctors said
scientific american february 1999 high
blood pressure and african americans
finally they started looking at this
seriously
and they went to nigeria out in the bush
where people never seen a doctor a
stethoscope
took their blood pressure and seven
percent of them had high blood pressure
came back the united states did a lot of
dna testing
they found a large pool of people whose
ancestors had originated in nigeria and
took their blood pressure 33 percent
they knew immediately it was not genetic
because it was genetic it'd be seven
percent seven percent or 33
33 you can't have the same gene pool
just different locations and have
different numbers and be genetic it's
not going to be genetic
so what's the difference between these
two groups of people these people living
out in nigeria out in the bush are still
putting their wood ashes
they're plant minerals that are left
when you burn away the carbon the wood
into their gardens they're still
mixing it with their food and cutting
their salt with it the people in atlanta
and chicago and miami and l.a they're
living on french fries and pepsi cola
and it gets in atlanta be coca-cola
right
and you're not supplement because people
don't put wood ashes into their food
anymore
i get people tell me you know they get
kind of cocky oh yeah well man i'm 25
years old man i'm fit
i don't need none of that stuff we were
given a lecture like this over at la
fitness center in atlanta
four or five years ago and about halfway
through the lecture good looking gal i
mean she was a 15.
if the 10 is the top she was a 15.
i mean she had it all and she said oh no
dr wallick it's not the nutrients it's
you need to do aerobics and physical
fitness and she just kind of saunters oh
no and half the people got up and walked
out with her i mean who knew who had the
power in that room she did she took
everybody out
because she's a personal trainer now the
tragedy that story is about two months
later i started getting all these calls
from atlanta hey i need that stuff
and after about the 20th call i said why
am i getting all these calls from
atlanta all at once
they said remember that gal who walked
out you know she's 32 years old
beautiful personal trainer
she dropped dead on the treadmill this
morning
[Music]
it went to zero
okay january 2005 british medical
journal
high blood pressure and black's not
genetic finally
yes thank you lord high blood pressure
in blacks is not genetic
high blood pressure in whites is not
genetic high blood pressure in humans is
not genetic high blood pressure is not
genetic
we can eliminate high blood pressure in
the black community in america 90 days
if everybody will do exactly what i tell
you
we can eliminate high blood pressure in
the black community in 90 days
is that simple and it's so simple it's
scary
high blood pressure is actually caused
by deficiency of the mineral calcium
and the deficiency of its cofactors and
you can take all the calcium you want
you might get
20 percent better but if you want to get
100 better you take the calcium and
all of the cofactors right there's 89
cofactors that go along with calcium
you need vitamin c you need vitamin a
you need boron you need vitamin d3
you need magnesium and manganese and and
so on you need all these nutrients if
you want the calcium to work right
and if you do that usually within a
couple of weeks you're taking your own
blood pressure now
in a couple weeks you'll see blood
pressure comes right down in the normal
range you're on medication
or a period of six to eight to ten weeks
you can wean off your medication you do
not want to cold turkey off your
medication then start taking the
nutrition
it takes a couple of days a couple of
weeks for that nutrition to kind of
rebuild the body and re-regulate it
but we can eliminate high blood pressure
and black community in america 90 days
if everybody would just do that little
system
it's a little nutritional program how
many ever heard with you believe it or
not
that cholesterol either directly or
indirectly has something to do
with cardiovascular disease coronary
heart disease sure everybody knows that
because doctors say so
we've known for 50 years that
cholesterol has nothing to do with
cardiovascular disease or coronary
artery disease elevated cholesterol
triglycerides
do not cause any diseases they do not
cause a single disease if you can find
any disease
this cause of elevated blood clots or
triglycerides will give you a million
dollars in small bills
tax free in any offshore account you
want i'm very very confident there's not
a single disease
that is caused by elevated blood
cholesterol triglycerides so just
lowering that
with a drug that causes blindness and
liver cirrhosis doesn't make sense when
you know that
because you're still going to die of
cardiovascular disease if that's all
you're doing what that indicates is you
might be deficient in
niacin or vitamin b3 might be deficient
in chromium vanadium two trace minerals
we need them for managing our blood
sugar we need it for managing our blood
fats
you can be deficient in the omega-3
essential fatty acids in fact american
longevity our company we sued the fda
so we could put this information on the
labels of our essential fatty acid
bottles and in our catalogs
because we've known this for 50 years
there's literally
millions of studies that have been done
on essential fatty acids and help
prevent stroke and heart attacks and the
fda wouldn't let people put on the
labels of their bottles their nutrient
supplements
so we had to sue them to get it so we're
very very proud that we did it nobody
else would join us they're afraid of
them you know so we just went after them
by ourselves
so if it's not cholesterol and
triglycerides that cause
coronary artery disease what is it what
causes coronary artery disease and
artery sclerosis and heart disease
how many ever heard of free radicals
raise your hand good
how many ever heard trans fatty acids
raise your hand well trans fatty acids
are free radicals
that come from things like vegetable
oils margarines
margin is perhaps the worst type of fat
not only for the heart but the body
it increases your risk of cardiovascular
disease it increases your risk of
coronary artery disease
alzheimer's disease macular degeneration
cataracts cancer
who told us to give up animal fats that
our 98 year old grandparents
used such as butter and lard and chicken
skin and all that kind of stuff
who told us to give all that up medical
doctors right
they told us to give that up and go to
margin well it turns out that margarine
is the cause of increased rate of
cardiovascular disease and coronary
artery disease
i like my patients to eat six to ten
eggs a day not fried remember nothing
fried but poached or soft scrambled and
butter
low temperatures soft boiled hard-boiled
i was glad to see this come out in march
of 1991 because
it showed that my 10 eggs are probably
pretty conservative normal cholesterol
in 88 year old man who's 25 eggs a day
and you have to ask why was this old
dude eating 25 eggs a day maybe he
didn't have any teeth and couldn't eat
steaks anymore
maybe owned an egg farm want to do his
own quality control
[Music]
but if you appreciate it 95 of the
weight of men's sex hormone testosterone
is made from a special steroid in the
body called cholesterol
you only make 10 of your daily need and
if you do not take in cholesterol
the odds are you're going to have some
problems you're not going to have enough
sex to be able to live longer right
and so this fella figured out on his own
he figured out on his own that the more
eggs he ate the more studly he became
another fact we've learned is that the
lower your cholesterol goes the more
stupid you become
there's somebody with low cholesterol
this came out february 14th uh
valentine's day of this year
and this is a big study big study and
they looked at almost 800 men eleven
hundred women they divided them into two
groups
those with cholesterol is below 200
which doctors are going to tell you is
good and those with cholesterol above
240 which doctor's gonna say is very bad
and it turns out that the ones who had
blood cholesterols above 240 were 80
percent smarter
than ones had blood cholesterol below
200. because it turns out that this
fatty insulation material the brain
myelin
is made out of 100 cholesterol it makes
up 75 of our brain weight
75 of your brain weight is fat
cholesterol so somebody says hey you're
a fat dad you say thank the lord
alzheimer's disease tidal wave is feared
14 million americans are going to die
of alzheimer's disease between march
2000 and
2025 14 million that's because they're
the ones who are following the doctor's
instructions and giving up eggs and
butter and red meat and chicken skin and
salt
the ones who eat those things are still
flying airplanes at 100.
getting a picture yeah vitamin e alone
can ease memory loss in alzheimer's
patients
[Music]
this came out a year and a half ago
january 2004 big study by johns hopkins
university
department of public health out of
medical school almost 5 000 men and
women over the age of 65.
people just taking vitamin c and e alone
were 78 less likely to have a diagnosis
of alzheimer's disease
you can reduce your risk of alzheimer's
disease by 78 just by taking two
vitamins c
and e what if you need eggs what if you
give up fried foods
what if you took selenium we can
eliminate diabetes in the black
community
in 90 days if you do what i'm just going
to tell you now just like high blood
pressure we can eliminate diabetes in
the black community
in 90 days this is a very simple
nutritional deficiency disease it's an
epidemic disease right now of course
there's a million new cases the united
states alone each year
this article came out june 2001 and
there's 32 million diabetics in america
right now 31 million of those 32 million
98 are adult-onset type diabetes or
insulin resistant diabetes
the reason why it's oftentimes called
insulin resistant diabetes is that the
diabetics
that have type 2 diabetes make 10 times
more insulin than non-diabetics
they make 10 times more insulin as
non-diabetics it's not an insulin
problem it's a deficiency of the
minerals and their cofactors that are
necessary for the insulin to work
now if you have a 1200 horsepower racing
engine and 400 octane racing gasoline
and you put that engine and that
gasoline all set up ready to go
inside of a dome that's just filled with
nothing but nitrogen you got the starter
outside and you're pushing that starter
real crank over right will it start
no because it's missing a cofactor
oxygen now you open that little
valve and you let the atmosphere in
there you get a little oxygen in there
now you push the button run that puppy
will run
the same thing is true with your insulin
you're missing those two
trace minerals under 23 cofactors when
you have adult onset type 2 diabetes
makes up 90 of the diabetic community
you take a little program and guess what
you take your blood sugar every morning
like you're supposed to watch it within
a week
right into the normal range and you're
able to wean off your medication go back
to normal life
diabetes is an easy disease to prevent
you don't want to get it before you
start worrying about it you want to
prevent it
and so you want to start doing this
stuff if you know you have in your
family it's not genetic but if your
family eats a particular way everybody
tends to eat in that family the same way
right
you have to watch it and this is an easy
disease to prevent it's a very very easy
disease to get rid of
you supplement properly obviously for
six months or so you gotta stay away
from sugar
still gotta watch that diet but as that
sugar comes down your blood sugar comes
down in the normal range you're able to
wean off your medication
because you are empowered to do that
when you're diabetic they teach you when
your blood sugar goes up you need more
medication blood sugar goes down you
need less medication
they teach you how to do that so you
just follow what you're instructed to do
and your next step will always be
self-evident historically adult onset
type 2 diabetes was
called adult onset type 2 diabetes
because it only occurred in people over
age 50.
well now babies are being born with it
primarily minority kids
little african-american kids and
hispanic kids are being born
with diabetes not because it's genetic
but because
there's none of these minerals in soul
food
now i'm not telling you to give up soul
food but i'm telling you if you want to
avoid diabetes you want to reverse you
got to supplement
you can eat any way you want except for
fried foods you got to give that up
right
it's an easy thing to deal with two
reasons why we have so much diabetes in
america today none of which are genetics
one of which is all the sugar we're
taking according to the us department of
agriculture
100 years ago americans were eating a
half a pound of sugar per person per
year
today reading 157 pounds of sugar per
person per year which is a half a pound
a day so in 100 years
we've gone from a half a pound of sugar
a year to a half a pound of sugar a day
you say well how do we get a half a
pound of sugar a day well there's krispy
kreme doughnuts dunkin donuts
there's pop tarts pillsbury toaster
strudels raisin bran
fruit loops cocoa puffs captain crunch
wheaties cheerios corn flakes and soft
drinks there's nine
teaspoons nine heaping teaspoons of
sugar per 12 ounce soft drink
if you drink 10 of those as 90 teaspoons
put 90 teaspoons in a bowl there's your
half a pound right there
plus you get crazy when you eat that
much sugar you go postal
well this was 91 000 nurses over an
eight year study harvard nurse's health
study
very recently again this was june 2004
they said if they drank one sugar sweet
and soda like a classic coke or pepsi
cola mountain dew
sprite seven up whatever they're 85
percent more likely to develop type 2
diabetes as those who drink less or
maybe none
water or tea some but if you drink two
of them a day you're going to get it
if you drink two sugar sweetened sodas a
day you're going to get it what about
these
teenage kids that drink two or three of
those 42 ounce gulps a day
and you wonder why they're 50 pounds 100
pounds overweight and they're going to
get diabetes
it's not genetic it's not a terrible
black gene it's the way they're eating
and we as the men of the family we can
solve that problem
but they're not going to like water
after drinking pepsi and coca-cola for
years
and so how do you deal with you saw
those diabetics get on that rebound fx
switch them to that tastes good you got
all these big athletes like shaq using
it you got theo using it
evander holyfield one of my heroes he um
is training for a big match for a big
boxing match coming up mid-september
he's using our products
so this is something you can do you
switch them off those things are going
to cause diabetes to switch them on
things that are good for them
that won't cause diabetes the second
thing that causes diabetes in america
now
is those two trace minerals no longer
found an optimal ounce in our food
i'll give you one of them you got to
read in the books for the others because
i would tell people about the two trace
minerals and 23 cofactors and never take
the 23 cofactors
and they get 10 better but it wouldn't
work completely because they forgot the
23 co-factors i want you to read it
and the book hell's kitchen and then
you'll figure it out the first tracer
i'm going to give you is chromium
everybody's heard of chromium it makes
your bumper shiny
they went back to 1948 went back to 1948
started getting frozen blood from
laboratories in 1948 there's a thousand
micrograms per liter parts per billion
of chromium and human blood in america
by 71 it dropped to 13 by 72 it dropped
to 10.
73 dropped to 4.7 to 5.1 by 74 it
dropped to 0.73 to 1.6
by 78 it was all the way down to 0.16
it's dropping like a rock because
nobody's putting the wood ashes the
plant minerals in our food in our
gardens anymore like we did
100 years ago and that's the problem and
so we have to consciously supplement
to make up that difference okay the last
disease we're going to talk about
we could go over 900 of them we only got
time for one more arthritis and
osteoporosis
according to the center for disease
control right out of atlanta here 85
percent of americans over the age of 50
already have osteoporosis and arthritis
of one type or another one degree or
another
there's not a single medical treatment
designed to prevent or fix it you saw
what happened to bo jackson great
two-sport athlete
football and baseball had a degenerative
hip disease that was just caused by
mineral deficiencies of course they
tried their big high tech hip
replacements and you now you say bo who
because you never heard of him again
after they did that and i'm sure they
convinced him
they were going to make him a bionic
athlete just let us put in two hips and
man you're gonna be fine
well he just sort of disappeared off the
landscape
and we learned 300 years ago in the
animal industry how to prevent and cure
arthritis and osteoporosis and animals
we've known how to do it in animals for
300 years if you give an animal a
commercially prepared diet and don't
give them any table scraps to mess up
the ratios in that commercially
prepared diet they'll live to be 20 25
years old today without arthritis and
osteoporosis 60 years ago some year old
enough like me to remember 60 years ago
an old dog lived to be 10 and you
thought he was doing good because
usually
six eight years old right and then you'd
eat them
now a dog lives to be 20 and they don't
get arthritis and osteoporosis
because they have all that stuff in the
dog food all we get is pain killers
and so we have to know more we have to
do it ourselves
because if you're dependent on the
medical system to do it for you you're
living in la
la land we have an epidemic of arthritis
because we have all these baby boomers
come along
who listen to doctors who think doctors
are it
i really appreciate pastor dollar's
position because he says why do you
listen to all those guys with those
doctors behind their name
when you should be listening to the good
lord right amen
the bad news is research shows that the
disease starts attacking your joints
long before middle ages starts when kids
are three years old to get arthritis and
osteoporosis
how many ever seen a kid with growing
pains
you know you go to a mall you sit down
just look at the kids you see this
mother who's only 85 pounds
carrying 120 pound kid on her hips
yeah and then she's got three other kids
and one of those 18 wheeler baby carts
had the big air horn
and that's because she's feeding those
kids nothing but apple juice and grape
juice
they think they're doing good because
i'm not giving my kids pop well how much
calcium is in grape juice
and apple juice zero plus you're gonna
make your kids crazy
and poor in school and they get three 12
ounce cans of mozzarell's apple juice a
day or three 12-ounce cans of welch's
grape juice a day
human being isn't meant to eat that way
now people say well yeah
i don't want to use that nutrition my
doctor is going to give me a fda
approved drug like
biox
27 billion worth of lawsuits against the
producer merck
because in the four years it was on the
market in four years on the market
vioxx caused 139 000 heart attacks
depending on whose data you looked at 55
000 five thousand those people died from
vioxx
and the fda never took it off the market
merc took it off the market because they
were getting sued so much they couldn't
afford to leave it on the market anymore
the fda never took it off the market how
many have ever heard of arthroscopic
surgery oh
there's a guy's head a couple of them
arthroscopic surgery for arthritis of
the knee is worthless
it's a worthless procedure when you have
arthritis do you think you just have
arthritis in your left knee which really
hurts bad bad
it's all over your body and if you'd go
in there and scrape that thing around
with arthroscopic surgery
does it fix your systemic arthritis
osteoporosis no
he's eventually going to do his thing
which is to remove it and put a
prosthesis or a plastic or metal one in
there
in 90 days you can rebuild your hips and
shoulders and fingers and toes and
ankles you can rebuild them
in 90 days just like theo did i just
love theo and his story
because he gives hope to everybody he
was told he was told that you're done
your career is over
all the best orthopedic surgeons in the
world cannot fix you and in 90 days just
with some simple little nutritional
programs
we built him back together now he's one
of the top athletes in the nba
top athletes in the world but he was
smart enough
to do it all other aspects now bo
jackson i'm going to get that bionic
double hip thing
yeah my orthopedic surgeons the same one
that did elizabeth taylor's 17 hip
operations
well if they were so good why do you
have to do the other 16 right
well the reason why these doctors
continue to do this even though it's a
worthless procedure and this was
published in the new england journal of
medicine
back in july of 2003 is because the 5
000 american doctors who specialize in
that procedure
their income for 2001 was 1.5 billion
dollars
that one procedure are they going to
give that up just because it's worthless
no you have to be tough when they come
to you and say roy you got bone to bone
arthritis you're needing i could go for
the big one and give you joint
replacement surgery but
we got this new thing called
arthroscopic surgery not clean that
thing up and
it'll last you an additional six months
when you have a failed and corrupt
system you have to stop using them
osteoporosis strikes both men and women
equally
we've known that for a hundred years
osteoporosis only became a
postmenopausal woman's problem in 1958
when the pharmaceutical industry
invented estrogen
that says true story we've known for 100
years that osteoporosis and arthritis
occur equally in both men and women
the reason why doctors don't focus on
men is because they can talk women into
a big lie
that estrogen will reduce their risk of
osteoporosis will reduce
actually reverse osteoporosis in either
statement which is true
but it does get rid of hot flashes which
make him happy now the results turn the
tables on the belief that women are the
prime victims of condition now this has
been known as
modern times since november 2001
they say this information will help
professionals deal with unexplained bone
fractures men and the way education
about the condition is handled
now how many of you gentlemen since
november of 2001
have received a phone call an email a
postcard or some kind of direct
communication from your medical doctor
saying look
we have just learned that osteoporosis
occurs equally in both men and women
i expect you to come in here immediately
for bone density test so we can get
ahead of this thing how many men have
received that communication in any way
shape or form for your medical doctor
this was published in every medical
journal in the land
in the world if they say they haven't
seen it
then i wouldn't go back to them because
they're supposed to be reading this
stuff right
i'm 65 years old
i'm telling you there's nothing wrong
with any of my joints
amen thank you lord
nobody's going to steal an airplane with
me on it
and so it's just a matter of giving your
body the raw materials and we're built
to last at least 120 years according to
god and i believe him
amen
[Applause]
thank you for listening to this
presentation and remember to contact the
person that sent this to you
for more presentations and books that go
into greater detail
go to doc wallockmedia.com and be well
make sure to check out our food youtube
channel called notice foods
this is 100 dr wallock approved
and the chef that is preparing the food
here and teaching you how to
follow dr wallach's food guidelines and
dr glidden's food guidelines
he's a industry professional over 22
years experience and a college diploma
to back it up
and we do have experienced cooks and
bakers as well working on content for
the youtube channel notice foods and the
instagram channel
notice foods so 100 gluten free
oil free all the stuff about burning
fats and all of the rules
that you would need to know or follow
we're here to teach it to you here
as well as give you tons of ideas for
recipes
individual dishes and meals of course in
the near future we do have a cookbook
coming out stay tuned for it
and definitely check out my newest book
fake diseases it covers all of the major
topics that come up
like birth defects blood sugar problems
bone and joint problems
cancer autoimmune problems and more and
it's on amazon for just 9.99
and the audiobook read-along version is
free here on youtube
the link for that is in the description
of this video
[Music]
you